Bat-fans are quickly forming a consensus opinion
about who they would like to see playing the
next Clown Prince of Crime.
The roster of villains for the upcoming The
Batman may already be set, but it seems only
a matter of time before the next cinematic
incarnation of the Joker arrives to vex Robert
Pattinson's Dark Knight.
The fan favorite choice for the role: Willem
Dafoe, who co-starred with Pattinson in last
year's Robert Eggers-directed psychological
horror flick The Lighthouse.
"His coral-tined trident screeches banshee-like
in the tempest, and plunges right through
your gullet!"
Now, it's obvious that fans have no say in
casting Hollywood productions, and you never
know - The Batman just might flop spectacularly,
thereby failing to even earn a sequel.
Having said that, we're going to go ahead
and file this fan-casting under "W" for "Why
the hell didn't we think of that?" - because
yeah, now that the notion of Dafoe as the
Joker is out there, it certainly seems like
the definition of a no-brainer.
The veteran actor is possessed of a wiry physicality
which is perfect for the role; his facial
structure and toothy grin are also custom-made
for Jokerdom, as evidenced by some twisted
fan art courtesy of Instagram user thesithlordjoker.
His role in The Lighthouse demonstrated in
one fell swoop that he has incredible chemistry
with Pattinson, and also that his skill at
portraying wild-eyed craziness as an actor
has in no way diminished over the years.
To top it all off, he already has experience
filling the shoes of an iconic supervillain.
But we'll get to that in a bit.
Fans on Twitter have been psyching themselves
up to see Willem play "da foe" of Pattinson's
Batman - see what we did there? - ever since
The Lighthouse dropped last October.
The flick is essentially a two-man stage production
with Dafoe and Pattinson continually one-upping
each other in the crazy department, and the
two actors' intense chemistry had light bulbs
popping up over the heads of Bat-fans far
and wide.
Twitter user @SEALkraven set the scene for
the idea, writing:
"Willem Dafoe as Joker, in a post-credit scene
of The Batman.
Just imagine."
Other users asserted that the Joker was nothing
less than the role that Dafoe was born to
play, and some expressed their shock that
such a spot-on casting choice had never come
to fruition before.
Oddly enough, it turns out that the idea of
casting Dafoe as the Clown Prince of Crime
has been had before - by the guy who wrote
the screenplay that would evolve into Tim
Burton's Batman.
In an interview with The Hollywood Reporter
in 2018, Dafoe recalled that Sam Hamm - who
wrote the initial drafts of Batman - had talked
him up for the role of the Joker, which of
course eventually went to Jack Nicholson.
Dafoe recalled:
"Hamm said something about how physi­cally
I would be perfect for the part, but they
never offered it to me."
Perhaps inevitably, though, Dafoe got his
chance to portray a cackling, unhinged supervillain
when he was cast as Norman Osborn's Green
Goblin in Sam Raimi's Spider-Man in 2002,
making his mark on one of the films that gave
birth to the modern superhero genre.
“We are who we choose to be… now, choose!"
“NO!"
Of course, he absolutely crushed the role
- although Raimi and screenwriter David Koepp
made the same mistake Hamm and script doctor
Warren Skaaren had made with Batman, killing
off the iconic villain in his very first appearance.
Since then, Dafoe has dipped his toes in the
superhero pool - so to speak - in 2018's Aquaman,
in which he popped up as the titular character's
friend and adviser Vulko.
This would probably not preclude him from
taking on the role of the Joker, though, as
many fans have theorized that The Batman and
its potential sequels will be set in a different
universe than the main DCEU timeline.
We would sure love for this bit of fan casting
to come to fruition, and we hope the people
in charge consider actually making the man
an offer.
Hey, Warner Bros.: You have the power to make
Bat-fans the world over freak out just by
giving the guy a call.
How about it?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.